thank you very much welcome everyone
it's the meeting with the uh the cabinet
of northern establishment council um
it's the 7th of july 2022. uh with me in
the room uh i'm
kendra alex dale i'm the leader of the
council
with kentucky fitness deputy leader
chester allen powell who's the portfolio
of the leisure uh cancer carolyn renick
portfolio holder for
um housing
alan marr who's governance officer we
hickey is founding director sarah
sternberg as monitoring officer and
james ethics as uh section 151 officer
and on the screen we have uh mark foster
he's champion member for council
services
so the first item is apologies for
absences
but i think we have uh council party
uh
and also council county
okay um the next item is decorations of
interest is there any that we want to
dispose
there's two items under exempt that um
myself and
um
as townball members but it's not pretty
interesting
okay
and then the next item would move to the
last meeting
and kind of remove it well i'll move
those
settings
all those in favor of recruiting those
carry
and then the next item is the medium
term financial
so the purpose of this report is to
inform carryover the outcome position
for the council of the financial year
2022 and it's also to approve the
rollover of small number of revenue
digits that we've been identified and
approved
as the
normal practice
program
so the publish this year's accounts on
26 of may ahead of the statutory
deadline which is the 31st of july this
year we wanted to do that to give the
auditors the best chance to be able to
complete in their time frame which is
currently the 20th of september
i won't go through the report in detail
but i'll just take a minute or two to
just highlight the key points
the general for netcast
position of the 31st of march was 478
000 pounds understand compared to the
revised budget
table one in the report shows the main
variances and we wrote the name on this
page it's largely due to a number of
they can post across the council as well
as savings on the casual budgets at the
leisure centres which we haven't needed
to utilize while we've been working with
uh centers that are closed so we've been
able to repurpose those very slightly
during that time the couple of budgets
that we're seeking approval for rollover
they're eight thousand pounds for church
law repairs and twenty eight thousand
pounds of rent living evaluations
both adjusters are working just as a
result of the work not being completed
upon your end they both progress well
this year so we will be spending them
during this financial year
in terms of the reserves they're all
detailed in pages two and three the main
point to note is that the transfer to
the general fund from the resilience
reserve was 397 000 less than would
originally forecast and that's largely
due to their non-pay that information
previously
there are very few variances amount on
the hra intended steve has more details
and there's been quite a lot of stupid
on the capital programme general fund
and hra and and in as in previous years
we're seeking pretty much roll those
over the main reasons for that was sort
of the tails and contractors in the
post-covered market in the first part of
the year was quite challenging but
things are a little bit easier we've got
additional questions now with custom
living that will be putting those back
to you
in the future
and finally just to summarize appendix 5
it produces a report on treasury
management activity i won't go through
that in any detail but the key point to
summarize for you at 2.30
so i'm happy to take any questions
sharing in fact if i could get back to
you to read the recommendations
let's try to understand any questions
no i'm happy to move then the
recommendation
[Music]
and all those in favor
thank you very much
back to the agenda
next i'd say is the
uh independent director of wrigley's
home for enumeration
yes thank you chad this is the
recommendation from the proposed to
increase
remuneration
um
by an independent company and the new
generation to compare
life-like organizations
we only have three independents and
is
absolutely agree with you i think it's
important that we attract um you know
the best possible beam will retain uh
the very good uh independent directors
that we have so
uh i'm happy to second are there any
other
comments
no okay all those in favor
okay let's carry it thank you very much
um item six is urgent items there are no
urgent items from me
uh so item seven and therefore uh move
that the public gets food from the
meeting
during the discussion of the following
items of business to avoid the
disclosure to them and exempt
information as defined in part one the
schedule 12 aid will open back to 1972
uh
yes